В ефірі випуск новин «heute 19 Uhr» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Добрий вечір! Ласкаво просимо до перегляду новин
цього суботнього вечора.
Руді Церне поділиться новинами спорту.
Добрий вечір!
Сьогодні ми підготували для вас такі теми:
Евакуація перед приходом росіян:
останні цивільні з лінії фронту Сходу України
виїжджають в безпечніші місця.
Зростання цін на енергоносії стає
соціальною проблемою.
Міністр праці та соціальної політики Губертус Гайль
вбачає можливе полегшення ситуації
в «кліматичних коштах» для людей із низьким
та середнім доходом.
«Червоні» та «білі» в очікувані одного -
фіналу Ліги Чемпіонів у Парижі.
«Мадрид» проти «Ліверпуля».
80 хвилин тривала телефонна розмова, під час якої
канцлер Німеччини та президент Франції
намагалися переконати Владіміра Путіна
припинити вогонь.
Безуспішно.
Президент Росії пропонує лише полегшити
експорт українського зерна,
та тільки за умови послаблення санкцій.
Крім того, він застерігає Захід
від подальшого постачання зброї.
Тим часом на Сході України він продовжує
активний і важкий наступ.
Репортаж Лютена Ляйнгоса.
Сєвєродонецьк - місто, за яке вже тривалий час
точаться бої -
ймовірно, не зможе більше протистояти наступу.
Перші російські підрозділи вторглися в будівлі на
околицях міста.
Серед них «сумнозвісні» угруповання
вірного Путіну
чеченського лідера Кадирова.
Це підтверджує також
голова місцевої цивільно-військової адміністрації:
«Наше становище погіршується.
У нас ще вистачає сил та ресурсів для захисту.
Не менш з тим, можливо,
буде наказ відходити нашим військам.
щоб не потрапити в оточення.»
Для Сєвєродонецька,
як і для його міста-побратима Лисичанська,
існує реальна загроза оточення.
Під російською окупацією наразі вже міста Лиман на Півночі
та Попасна на Півдні.
Лише Бахмут залишається підконтрольним Україні.
Лисичанськ вже тривалий час перебуває
під безперервним вогнем росіян.
Українська військова техніка залишає місто,
в той час як солдати та поліцейські
все ще намагаються евакуювати
травмоване населення в безпечне місце.
Це жахливо.
Такого я нікому не побажаю.
Заради Бога, це страшно.
Екстрена евакуація відбувається також у Бахмуті,
що знаходиться недалеко від лінії фронту.
Росіяни неподалік і вони наступають.
Місто Бахмут в зоні високого ризику.
Ми намагаємося евакуювати
якомога більше людей
на випадок,
якщо Україні доведеться відступати.
Пункт призначення -
залізничний вокзал міста Покровськ.
Тут курсують евакуаційні рейси на Захід України.
Соняшникова олія, зерно, сталь - товари з України,
які користуються попитом.
До війни економіка там зростала.
Наразі війна гальмує не тільки виробництво,
але й експорт.
Він скоротився на більш ніж 50%.
У четвертому за величиною місті країни, в Дніпрі,
виготовляються сталеві продукти для Німеччини.
Про проблеми з місця подій
повідомляє Геннер Геберштрайт.
Серце важкої промисловості України у Дніпрі
також не змогло уникнути наслідків війни.
Найсучасніший в Україні й один із найсучасніших
металургійних заводів у Європі
змушений був призупинити функціонування на тижні.
Наразі ж завод поступово відновлює роботу.
Наприкінці березня ми почали працювати над
замовленнями,
які залишилися ще від початку війни.
На початку квітня
нам вдалося доставити продукцію принаймні
нашим клієнтам в Європі.
У мирний час підприємство забезпечує робочими
місцями близько 10 000 осіб
на 5 заводах, що розташовані на околицях Дніпра.
Підприємство в основному постачає
продукцію знержавіючої сталі,
як от труби чи залізничні колеса,
до Європи, США та Середнього Сходу.
На початку бойових дій підприємство
призупинило виробництво.
Майже 800 співробітників були мобілізовані
на військову службу.
Ми постійно контактуємо
з ними й забезпечуємо їх найнеобхіднішим:
захисним одягом та аптечками.
Якщо ці висококваліфіковані
фахівці невдовзі не повернуться
до своїх робочих місць, це торкнеться також і ЄС -
більш ніж кожне друге
колесо потяга виготовляється в Україні.
І навіть те, що завод нині в змозі виготовляти,
є складною задачею для логістів.
Наші транспортні експерти постійно шукають можливості
здійснювати постачання принаймні до Європи.
Їх перевезення можливо наразі лише
вантажівками або ж потягами.
Через блокаду портів Росією здійснити
транспортування кораблем неможливо.
Ці колеса для вантажних вагонів поки доставити
також не вдалося.
Їх замовником є Deutsche Bahn (Німецька залізниця).
Через війну та інфляцію у Німеччині також
значно зросли ціни на енергоносії
та продукти харчування.
З допомогою так званих «кліматичних коштів»
міністр праці та соціальної політики Губертус Гайль
хоче підтримати людей з низьким
та середнім рівнем доходу.
На сьогодні уряд вже підтримав
різноманітні послаблення:
знижка на пальне
та на часте користування транспортом,
а також квиток за 9 євро.
На додачу до цього -
300 євро єдиної виплати на ектроенергію та
скасування відрахування
за відновлювану електроенергію.
Крім цього, ті, хто потребує, отримає
20 євро більше допомоги на кожну дитину
та субсидію на опалення.
Про наступні кроки міністра Гайля
знає Патріція Відемейєр.
За словами міністра праці Гайля, будуть ухвалені заходи
задля полегшення фінансового становища
людей з низьким і середнім рівнями
доходів, а також безробітних.
Наступного року планують реалізувати ініціативу
«кліматичних коштів»,
які слугуватимуть компенсацією
за підвищення витрат на енергію
та продукти харчування.
Ми повинні знати, як діяти, якщо такі високі ціни
на енергію та продукти харчування
залишатимуться тривалий період.
Тому я за те, щоб ми організовували
цільову допомогу
для людей з низьким і середнім рівнем
доходів в Німеччині.
Я пропоную
впровадити соціальні «кліматичні кошти»,
які б полегшили фінансове становище людей, які
не мають ресурсів або мають зовсім мало.
«Кліматичні кошти» зорієнтовані на сімʼї
з одним «годувальником»
з місячною заробітною платою до 4 000 євро брутто
та на одружені пари з доходом менше ніж 8000 євро.
Загальна сума допомоги визначається
у десятках мільярдах євро,
є соціально диференційованою
та фінансується коштом ціноутворення на вуглець.
В той час як партія «Зелених» підтримує пропозицію,
міністр фінансів від партії FDP Крістіан
Лінднер налаштований скептично.
В інтерв'ю одному з видань він висловився таким чином:
"Оскільки борги та підвищення податків виключені,
я з нетерпінням хочу побачити,
яким чином відбудеться фінансування цієї ідеї.
Замість того, щоб створювати щось нове,
реалістичнішим буде ухвалити реформи податків
на доходи фізичних осіб та прибуток.
Критика опозиції.
Нам обіцяли просте й доступне врегулювання:
300 євро «кліматичних коштів» для
кожного - від дитини до бабусі.
В результаті ми отримуємо проєкт допомоги,
яка дістанеться далеко не всім.
Проєкт складний і викликає багато запитань.
Здається, у коаліції ще не достатньо обговорили
пропозицію міністра праці.
Багато деталей, як-от коли, як, в якому обсязі
люди отримають «кліматичні кошти»
та чи отримають взагалі, залишаються відкритими.
Державні інвестиційні
гарантії повинні захистити німецькі компанії
від політичних ризиків із закордону.
Проте Міністерство економіки
вперше відхилило такі гарантії для проєкту в Китаї.
Причина - порушення прав людини.
Після масштабного витоку файлів стало відомо
про утримання членів мусульманської меншини уйгурів
у таборах перевиховання у регіоні Сіньцзян.
Саме в цьому регіоні перебувала Верховна
комісарООН з прав людини Мішель Башле,
де вона стала обʼєктом жорсткої критики.
Виникають питанням, що їй там показали
і чого вона може досягти.
США ж вважає поїздку до Китаю за таких умов помилкою.
Репортаж Ульфа Роллера.
Нові документи підтверджують жорстоке поводження
у таборах у регіоні Сіньцзян.
Шокуючі фото показують весь жах.
Під виглядом боротьби з тероризмом
у Китаї відбувається
пригноблення мусульманської меншини.
Про порушення прав людини Мішель Башле
у своїй промові говорить завуальовано.
Майже тиждень вона подорожувала провінцією Сіньцзян.
Цей візит не є розслідуванням.
Але я закликаю Китай переглянути свої методи
боротьби з тероризмом, щоб переконатися,
що вони відповідають міжнародним стандартам прав людини.
Вони – це голос жертв.
Всесвітній конгрес уйгурів.
І вони розчаровані, що
комісар ООН з прав людини
мовчить про злочини.
Жінок стерилізують,
в тюрмах їх катують та ґвалтують.
І той, хто був в такому місці й продовжує мовчати,
я вважаю, повинен негайно подати у відставку.
Це був не найкращий день для прав людини,
але хороший день для можновладців Пекіна.
Незважаючи на беззаперечні докази,
міжнародна організація не наважується
притягнути Китай до відповідальності.
Ці обличчя висувають звинувачення,
але комісар з прав людини
не дала їм право голосу.
Повернемося до новин Німеччини і
до незрозумілих знижок.
Наразі не так і легко розпізнати,
чи певна пропозиція
справді вигідна, чи це тільки приманка.
Дещо прояснити ситуацію зможе новий закон,
згідно якого знижені ціни можна буде порівняти
з попередніми,
а інформація на ціннику стане зрозумілішою.
Репортаж Ансельма Штерна.
Рутинні закупи стають все дорожчими,
а цінники і порівняння цін - все важливішими.
Нові правила мають в цьому допомогти.
Наприклад, супермаркет.
Він повинен вказати так звану початкову ціну
продуктів у літрах або кілограмах.
Наразі ж є багато варіантів, які важко простежити.
Таким чином час для обчислення знижки споживачами
скорочується.
Бо ж раніше деякі початкові ціни
зазначалися, до прикладу, для 100 грамів.
Натомість у майбутньому таке зустрічатиметься
лише в особливих випадках.
Крім цього в рекламі зміниться й багато інших речей.
Супер пропозиції, класні проценти -
відтепер фізичні та онлайн магазини
повинні фактично доказати
наскільки реально знижується вартість товарів.
Тому вони повинні вказати,
якою була найнижча ціна
за останні 30 днів.
Це допоможе швидше зрозуміти,
чи це насправді вигідна покупка.
Чітка критика походить від торгової асоціації.
Насамперед, це непотрібні зусилля.
Найбільша проблема полягає в тому,
що з новим регламентом виникає
не більше захисту споживачів,
а багато невизначеності для торгівлі.
Якщо ми повинні вказувати
найнижчу ціну на певний товар
за останні 30 днів,
це унеможливлює певні зниження цін.
Якщо ви хочете знизити ціну на 20%
на весь асортимент,
то відстежити це за тисячами цін неможливо.
Німецькі рітелейри попереджають, що буде
дедалі рідше зниження цін,
менше промо-кампаній.
Захисники прав споживачів, навпаки,
підтримують нові правила,
адже тепер покупці зможуть порівнювати ціни
набагато краще і швидше.
Ознайомитися з новими правилами
для покупок в Інтернеті
можна в додатку «ZDFheute».
План боротьби з коронавірусом на осінь
вимагає голова Всесвітньої медичної асоціації
Монтгомері і керівник Інституту Роберта Коха Вілер.
За словами Монтгомері, кількість хворих
неминуче зросте знову,
і для того, щоб однаково протидіяти
цьому по всій країні,
необхідно буде переглянути
Закон про захист від інфекцій,
включаючи можливість локдауну.
Показники інфекцій в країні
знижуються вже кілька тижнів,
а разом з ними і семиденна захворюваність.
Інститут Роберта Коха повідомляє,
що зараз цей показник становить 209,4.
Не тільки коронавірус є причиною
скорочення числа парафіян.
Католицька церква перебуває в глибокій кризі.
Ніколи раніше від неї
не відверталося так багато людей.
І З'їзд католиків, колись магніт для мас,
тепер привалює меншу кількість людей.
Андреас Лінке з висновками зі Штутгарта.
П'ять днів центр Штутгарта
знаходився під знаком 102-го З'їзду католиків.
1500 подій:
лекції, круглі столи,
концерти, церковні служби.
Тим, хто там був, сподобалося,
що там не дуже людно.
Кожен знайде щось для себе.
І потрібно просто постаратися організувати дні так,
щоб взяти з цього для себе якомога більше.
І це безперечно так, для мене це джерело сили.
У мене зараз немає відчуття,
що заходів менше,
навпаки, багато людей зібралися разом,
незважаючи на несприятливі обставини.
У цій події взяли участь близько 25 тисяч осіб,
що на третину менше,
ніж попереднього З'їзду католиків в Мюнстері.
Занепад, який відображає
зменшення кількості прихожан.
Останнім часом в Німеччині люди,
які належать до християнської церкви,
перебувають у меншості.
Ми бачимо, що частково немає відчуття безпеки,
що є результатом пандемії, -
не всі заходи відбуваються на вулиці.
Ми також бачимо, і ми не хочемо заперечувати,
що люди втратили бажання
бути частиною цієї церкви.
Ми повинні боротися за те,
щоб їх не ставало значно менше.
Вдень у Штутгарті:
Демонстрація ініціативи «Марія 2.0» бореться
за відкриття церковних посад для жінок.
Побажання щодо реформ різноманітні.
І велике розчарування викликає
їхнє повільне впровадження
та нерішуче роз'яснення скандалів,
пов'язаних зі зловживанням.
Завтра З'їзд католиків закінчиться
завершальною церковною службою.
Щодня ми бачимо та чуємо
повідомлення про жах війни в Україні,
жахаємося руйнувань і страждань.
Але що таке війна насправді,
знають лише ті,
хто пережив її сам. Наприклад, Другу світову війну.
Флоріан Корчик
про страхи та рани довжиною в життя,
які зараз знову розривають.
Це жахливо.
Задумливі Петер та Сюзанна Гальвіц
стежать за новинами з України.
Кадри нової війни пробуджують у них старі спогади.
Ми згадуємо, як ми це пережили.
Розбомблені будинки.
Люди на вулиці,
що несуть останні свої речі в руках.
Як ми повинні були захищатися
від вогню, від бомб, від атак,
від гранат, що летять звідусіль.
Як і вони, багато людей похилого віку,
яким довелося пережити
Другу світову війну відчувають те саме.
Довгий час вони не говорили про свої особисті долі
в асоціації переміщених осіб в Ерфурті,
але тепер все інакше.
Кілька авіаційних атак, які я пережив особисто.
Моя сестра була зґвалтована.
На жаль, спогади повернулися
і впоратися з ними нелегко.
Всі вони в той час були ще дітьми,
та їхні глибокі страхи довгий час не виявлялися.
Ці спогади зберігаються таким чином,
що можуть прийти будь-якої миті
і серйозно вплинути на життя.
Це те, що ми називаємо травматичними спогадами.
І саме ті картинки,
які ми зараз бачимо по телевізору,
можуть викликати такі спогади.
За словами психолога, найкраще допомагає
говорити про це.
А ввечері просто переключитися,
щоб відволіктися.
Або принаймні спробувати це зробити.
Що зазвичай добре допомагає
відключитися і відволіктися,
так це спорт.
Насамперед футбол, Руді.
Сьогодні йтиметься про найважливіший титул
в європейському клубному футболі.
Фінальний матч Ліги чемпіонів
на «Стад де Франс» в Парижі
між англійським «Ліверпулем»
і мадридським «Реалом».
Дві команди укомплектовані суперзірками.
Все це в прямому ефірі на ZDF.
Йохен Брейєр з Парижу. Хто ваш фаворит?
Дуже складне питання.
Для мене це гра без фаворитів,
саме це робить вечір таким захоплюючим.
«Ліверпуль» - найпослідовніша команда року,
вони програли лише одну гру цього року.
Ось вони від'їжджають від готелю.
«Реал Мадрид» - найуспішніший клуб
Ліги чемпіонів.
Вони виграли навіть в тих іграх,
які здавалися програними.
Результат очевидний.
Ось така картина в місті -
дуже багато червоного та білого кольорів.
Це буде атмосферний вечір.
Ми з нетерпінням чекаємо на футбольне свято
і відразу повідомимо вам результати з Парижа.
Дякую, Йохен Брейєр.
Жіноча футбольна команда ФК «Вольфсбург»
виграла фінал Кубка Німецького футбольного союзу
у ФК «Турбіне Постдам».
Команда тренера Томі Штроота перемогла
з рахунком 4:0 в Кельні.
Для ФК «Вольфсбург» це восьмий титул поспіль.
Картина залишається незмінною
вже восьмий рік поспіль.
Футболістки ФК «Вольфсбург»,
включаючи воротарку Альмут Шульт,
що завершує кар'єру, піднімають Кубок DFB.
З самого початку команда тренера Томмі Штроота
не сумнівається, що переможе в Кельні.
На 11 хвилині Пайор, подавши кутовий удар,
вивела команду вперед.
Перш ніж Потсдам встиг відповісти,
польська національна гравчиня
знову забила гол головою
трохи більше ніж за півгодини - 2:0.
З рахунком 3:0 від Роорда
результат було вирішено ще до перерви.
Після перерви завдяки голу Янссен рахунок 4:0.
То був дев'ятий поспіль тріумф з Кубком
в історії Нижньої Саксонії.
Жодній іншій жіночій команді
не вдавалося це раніше.
Гандбольна команда «СК Магдебург»
знову у фіналі Європейської Ліги.
У півфіналі турніру «Фіналу чотирьох» у Лісабоні
захисники обіграли хорватський клуб «Nexe Nasice»
з рахунком 34:29.
Шарль Леклер забезпечив собі лідируючу позицію
в Монако.
Недільна погода залишає бажати кращого.
Завтра вона буде прохолодною і мінливою.
Подробиці Кріста Орбен повідомить
найближчим часом.
О 21:45 Марієтта Сломка
повідомить вам останні новини.
А ми дякуємо вам
і бажаємо гарних вихідних.
Побачимось завтра, до побачення.
Добрий вечір.
Завтра на нас чекає найпрохолодніший день.
Між цією областю низького тиску
над Скандинавією
та областю високого тиску над Великобританією
прохолодне повітря надходить безпосередньо до нас
з північного заходу, що принесе нам завтра
температуру близько 15°,
тоді як на Піренейському півострові
можлива літня температура - 35°.
Вночі температура знизиться
з 10 до 3°.
У центральній частині можливі заморозки.
Тут місцями проясниться, але на інших територіях
вночі буде хмарно і можливі невеликі дощі.
Штормовий північно-західний вітер
поступово стихає.
А завтра очікується знову мінлива погода,
що більше є типовим для квітня.
Найясніша погода очікується
на південному заході країни,
частково також в районі Лаузіца.
Хмари прямують на північ та північний захід,
але набагато щільніші ніж сьогодні.
Короткочасні зливи та грози можуть бути скрізь,
але найбільш поширені на південному сході країни
та від західного центру до Балтійського моря.
І до того ж досить
прохолодні для травня температури -
максимум від 11 до 18° вдень.
На новому тижні очікується
підвищення температури.
За подібної погоди в середу
температура становитиме від 20 до 26°
і намічаються нові грози.